this Mega star who is undressing me with
his eyes Jessica Simpson continues to be
an open book I really wanted to share my
journey with everyone two years after
the release of her tell-all Memoir Jess
is spilling more secrets in a new essay
titled movie star they always say
they're single in the story published
Wednesday by Amazon just details a
never-before-revealed romance she had
with a mystery movie star all while he
was in a relationship she met the
unnamed celeb at the 2001 MTV VMAs when
she and her ex Nick Lachey were on a
break this Mega star who I grew up
thinking was so hot eyeballed me up and
down like he was undressing me with his
eyes nothing happened that night but the
two wound up running into each other at
the gym soon after and Jessica invited
him to be be in an upcoming music video
you could be the lead guy I offered to
this man who made millions and millions
per film Jess gave the guy her number
but that music video moment never came
to be because she and Nick rekindled
their romance and later got married
people
um can see that Nick and I are in love
Flash Forward to 2006 Nick and Jess
finalized their divorce and the singer
says she reconnected with the mystery
man hooking up at the Beverly Hills
Hotel before she saw a pic of him with
his actual girlfriend on a red carpet I
was never in a million years going to be
the other woman but he called me it's
completely over he told me you were the
only girl I want to be with Jess
believed all that because the two were
essentially dating going out to clubs
together and hanging out at friends
houses plus she says he invited her to
join him on a film set in New York Jess
claimed she had to enter the hotel from
a private entrance seemingly as a way to
dodge the Press but later realized he
was sneaking her in for another reason
this was to hide me from his chick I
didn't care if he was my teenage fantasy
come to life while the internet work to
figure out who this guy was we know we
can rule out a few suspects from Jess's
past public affairs she's had a series
of high-profile romances Beyond her
marriage to Nick with Nick I was madly
in love I thought I knew my future and I
thought he was going to be in it forever
she's also been linked to Johnny
Knoxville Tony Romo and John Mayer John
is an
extremely alluring
personality I mean he walks into a room
and he is the room she found her happily
ever after with hubby Eric Johnson whom
she married in 2014 and shares three
kiddos with we're very happy and we know
how to make babies very well yeah just
doesn't shy away from dishing all the
Deets and back in 2020 she told E.T why
she keeps it real I wanted people to
know the ups and the downs and the
struggles and the things that we have to
go back through in our life I am an open
book
[Music]
thank you